school district in missouri going super
old-fashioned and they're bringing back
spanking children who really act up
maybe they lob too many spit balls
will now be swatted on the buttocks with
a paddle as a quote last resort
parents have to be okay with it and give
the school their explicit written
permission but get this some moms and
dads have been thanking the school for
doling out the discipline
you got paddled second grade do you
agree with this form of punishment it
worked it did work
i got two i never happened again i got
spanked that day two times my pen once
my parents learned they were so
embarrassed
they took matters in their own hands
when i got home as well so i don't have
as much of an issue with this
so is this legal apparently it's legal
yeah the united states supreme court
said it's legal it's up to the
individual states as to whether or not
they're going to allow it the whole
concept is that a teacher is in loco
parentis a teacher is in the place of
the parent
and the school districts are smart
they're basically saying to the parents
look if you want to give us permission
to whack your kid not in the new york
sense but to pass take them out right to
have your kids
and they say apparently it's between one
and three paddles but they don't say the
age i assume it's grammar school i doubt
it's high school you know
we never did this in the northeast did
we no but in fact out of the 19 states
you'd use it they say mostly them in the
south yeah but uh but my data was
described uh everyone got hit in school
and it was mostly by nuns
nuns uh they were they were a lot
angrier back then evidently for the
short fuse yeah
they had a bad day bad morning whatever
it was you're getting hit but and that
was a pretty good generation won a few
wars everybody seemed happy although the
tv wasn't black and white they could
have accelerated that a little bit but i
would say this the threat of having the
paddle just saying listen your parents
signed the form you want the paddle
that's enough
just the mere threat of the paddle yeah
we'll keep you in line me for sure you
especially my mom it was the wooden
spoon and oh for eating did you not eat
no no no for spanking if i got in
trouble my mother would use it if i
didn't eat oh no no this would be
invited something bad sounds like you
guys have an eating disorder
so this coming up this weekend lawrence
jones on his cross-country show on
saturday night is going to be talking to
several teachers about the teacher
shortage and the problem and there is a
teacher shortage i hope you understand
that all right but anyway one of the
things that some of these teachers are
saying is that many are leaving because
the students in the classroom there are
just behavioral issues that are out of
control the disrespect for teachers is a
huge problem and they got exacerbated
after remote school kids come back and i
can understand parents may be saying
look if i'm not there and they do
something really bad maybe so however
we're also saying we won't want teachers
to deal with sensitive topics like
gender issues for example you prefer to
do that at home i think that in my
opinion if i had children i would want
to take care of the paddling myself can
you paddle female students yeah
yeah there's no distinction on the bot
right not in the hand on the butt it's
on the button and how many smacks do you
get i think three up to three three and
you cannot cause physical harm well
what's the line what physical harm tears
physical injury tears don't count no
where you leave a mark where you leave a
mark yeah how do you know
the parents will tell you when the kid
gets here's you know what we're gonna
hear about suing the kids are going to
sue the school because it did leave a
mark the butt will never be the same i
could see this the parents that agreed
to the spanish
thing
a lot more permission to see a lot more
law firm commercials around this over
the years
we're going to talk about paddling more
in the breakup hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now